- I don't know if this is true,
because this is an odd place to start,
but did you perform in libraries?
Is this a real thing?
- I did preform in libraries,
yeah.
- (laughing) Like, I feel
like you're supposed to
be quiet in libraries.
- That's true typically.
- I love you,
you're always doing something
different than the norm.
- Yeah.
- So how did that,
like what?
- It sounds crazy.
- [Kelly] It sounds crazy.
- That's a non-descript.
- Okay.
- There was an afterschool
program when I was growing up,
- Okay.
called YOUmedia that was at
the Harold Washington Library
downtown in Chicago,
and one day I was walking
down the street after school,
and somebody was like, "Hey,
we got a studio in here,"
and I was like, "That's a library."
He was like, "It's both,"
(audience laughing)
and-
- That's cool.
- Yeah, so I came in and checked it out,
and they had free studio time
for all kids
- What?
- that were 18 and under.
They had like free production classes,
like, I'm nice with it,
'cause I was literally at the same time
that I was going to high school,
and not paying attention to class,
I was paying hella attention
in this afterschool program.
- Yeah.
- And they had this open mic program there
called Lyricist Loft
that was ran by my mentor,
and a lot of people's
mentors outta Chicago,
Vic Mensa, and NO NAME,
and Sava, and Mick,
a lot of people went to this program,
like, people around my age,
that kinda blew up in
hip-hop from Chicago.
Yeah, and we would do
this open mic program,
and he would like, you know,
show us what we were doing wrong,
and help us get better as performers.
I did that from when I was like 14
to like 18, really 19.
They had to like, kick
me out of the program,
(audience laughing)
'cause I was trying
to stay in there.
- I know I would've
loved that opportunity.
Like, that studio time is expensive.
- [Chance] Yeah.
- Like, that's an incredible opportunity.
- Yeah, it changed my life.
- It's so cool.
- It changed all of our lives,
everybody that came there,
and it was free.
- Yeah.
- It was just like, you just had to come.
- That is awesome.
- Yeah.
- Just showing up and people
help you out, awesome.
Well, you recently put on a huge festival,
we were talking about it,
it was in Ghana, right?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Tell everybody
why you started this.
- Yeah, so, in January, we just had
the first successful
Black Star Line Festival.
- [Kelly] That's so cool. (clapping)
(audience clapping)
- [Chance] Yeah.
- [Kelly] And it's huge.
Wasn't it like 50,000 people?
It's like some crazy number.
- Yeah,
50,000 people, 52,000 people
in Accra, Ghana,
that's in West Africa.
Ghana has been like, the stronghold
of like, Black liberation,
anti-imperialism, Pan-Africanism,
a lot of like, ideals,
that we as a people hold near and dear,
and are a big part of our liberation,
have been like,
you know, uplifted by Ghana, historically,
like, since the fifties,
since they got their independence,
and me and Vic Mensa,
one of my closest friends,
wanted to put together an event
that Black people could travel to,
and, you know, be in
confidence and hang out,
and be safe and listen to great music.
We had T-Pain, Erykah Badu,
Sarkodie, Jeremih,
myself and Vic performed,
a bunch of awesome people.
Dave Chappelle did a talk down there.
It was like a basically a week
long festival of activities
that were free for people from abroad,
Black people from abroad,
to come together and kick
it and learn some stuff.
- I love that you became
what someone gave you
when you were a kid.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
You're walking by and someone said,
"Hey, you can come do this
and be a part of this,"
and you're working with all
these different artists,
and it, kind of, is like,
the evolution of that,
like what you're doing
for all these artists,
and say, "Hey, come
here, this is like, free.
You can come and have a good
time," and that's awesome.
- Yeah, no, totally.
- I don't know if you put
that together, but I just did.
You're welcome.
- No, I appreciate you
putting that together.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- No, it's totally what it is.
I would not be here
if it wasn't for the programs I went to,
the free things that people did,
or like the mentorships
that certain men and women
gave me when I was a shorty,
that just made me think a certain way;
and I feel like that's what we
as a people historically did,
was we lived in communal
spaces and like, you know,
helped the next people
understand how things work,
and, yeah.
- It's a really cool domino effect.
- [Chance] Absolutely.
- I'm just pointing it out.
- You're so wise.
- Yeah, I'm so wise,
It's really what I am.
- You are, that's what it is.
- So, wait, so you've partnered
with a few artists to make,
this is cool, your album cover art?
- Yes.
- Was this on purpose?
Like, you went out to find these artists?
- So, what's been happening is I've been,
since my first trip to Ghana,
I met with,
I stayed with, like a group
of this collective of artists,
painters and photographers, and such,
from West Africa,
but from a bunch of different countries,
and really just got to like, you know,
getting to know them,
and getting to understand
how their, you know,
how their field works,
and realize there's a lot of similarities,
overlapping of like, the exploitation
of, you know, music artists,
and the exploitation of visual artists.
- Yeah.
- And through that, like,
we just had a conversation about
how to create more community
and collaborate together.
- [Kelly] Better network.
- Yeah, so now,
my next project is called
"Star Line Gallery."
It's a collaboration with
16 different visual artists,
fine artists from around the world,
Black folks that I met through my travels,
where we got together, and
I went through my medium,
they went through their medium,
and we came together to make a piece.
So, so far I've released four of them.
They're in the-
- That's so cool.
- Major institutions,
the MOCA in Los Angeles,
The Museum of Contemporary
Arts in Chicago,
Art Basel, Switzerland.
Those are some of the things.
- That's so cool!
- Yeah, so that's Mía Lee,
is an amazing painter from Chicago,
she did "Yah Know."
Naïla Opiangah, she
painted "Child of God."
Nikko Washington.
- Who did this one up here?
- That one up top is,
Yannis Davy Guibinga,
he's an amazing photographer
from Gabon, Africa,
and he lives in Toronto.
But, he's phenomenal.
- That is a cool shot.
- Yeah, that's the thing,
it's like, as artists,
we're communicators,
high-level communicators,
and we have these conversations
that we need to get out to the world,
and sometimes it takes like,
collaboration between two artists
to really like, get across the point.
So like, when you get a chance,
check out that one that you like,
that's "The Highs and The Lows."
Check out "The Highs and The Lows."
- Of course, I like that one, sure.